All small towns have their horror stories,
tales of places plagued by terrifying apparitions,
unseen forces, and something waiting in the
shadows to terrorize unsuspecting innocents.
Sometimes it's a bridge at the edge of town
where a man in a bunny suit stalks, wielding
an ax and looking for drivers who wander off
of the main road.
Sometimes it's a cabin in the woods rumored
to house an old, gnarled witch who steals
people away and throws them into a giant soup
pot.
Maybe it's a cursed hotel where wicked spirits
roam the halls, and the guests check-in, but
never check out.
Or maybe, like the little town where 16-year-old
Mark lived, it's a haunted house.
Ever since he was a little boy, Mark had been
terrified of the house at the end of the lane.
He walked past it on his way to school each
morning, and on his way back in the late afternoon.
The sight of it made his palms sweat, his
heart beat just a little faster.
It had once been a grand Victorian manor,
with turrets and a wraparound porch, painted
a brilliant white.
But over the years, the paint had faded to
a dingy yellow, peeling away from the rotting
wood.
There were holes in the roof where the rain
and snow dripped through between the shingles.
The windows were caked with dust and grime,
obscuring anything that might be hiding inside.
Not that there should have been anything there.
The house had been abandoned for decades.
Still, whenever he passed it, Mark could swear
he felt the presence of something in there.
Pacing, watching, waiting for him to come
inside.
The stories around town didn't help.
His parents told him to ignore them, said
that people just liked to talk when there
was nothing else to do, to make up things
to be afraid of because their lives were too
boring otherwise, but he couldn't avoid it.
On a Boy Scouts trip when he was twelve, Mark
had tried to cover his ears when the other
boys gathered around the campfire with him
turned the topic to the old house, but they
teased and taunted him until he listened.
They leaned in, faces lit ghoulishly from
below by the flickering orange flames, and
whispered about the ghost that had taken up
residence in the house.
A wealthy old woman had lived there a long,
long time ago, they said.
She was cruel, with a nasty temper.
Everyone in town knew to avoid her, knowing
she would throw things at them from her window,
shout at them, even sic her guard dogs on
them.
But one group of boys in town couldn't resist
giving her a good scare.
They dressed up in all black, red devil masks
covering their faces, and broke into her house
late one night.
When she awoke, they were standing at the
foot of her bed, holding pitchforks and telling
her they had come to drag her to hell.
Her heart stopped from pure terror at the
sight.
But her spirit lingered in the house, swearing
revenge against anyone who ever dared cross
her threshold again.
Especially teenage boys.
Mark didn't sleep a wink the whole camping
trip after hearing that.
He swore then and there that, no matter what,
he would never go into that house.
But everyone can be bought, and everyone has
a price.
For Mark, the price was a car.
He had been saving up as best as he could,
but it was tough to get a job with no way
to transport himself there, and mowing lawns
for his neighbors wasn't the most lucrative
gig.
So, when he learned that his neighbor Oliver,
home on a break from college, was getting
rid of his old car, he begged to buy it.
He doubted Oliver would go for it, knowing
what a jerk the guy could be, but to Mark's
surprise, Oliver gave him an offer.
"I'll tell you what..."
Oliver's face broke into a sadistic smile.
"I'll give you the car.
If you can spend the whole night in the house
at the end of the street.
Alone."
"Are you serious?!"
Mark scoffed.
"Dead serious.
Make it to sunrise without freaking out and
bailing, and the car's yours.
Do we have a deal?"
Oliver stuck out his hand to shake.
Every nerve in Mark's body was screaming at
him to say no, but if he didn't agree, he
wouldn't be able to afford a car until he
was in college.
With a defeated sigh, he took Oliver's hand.
"Deal."
But as night fell and Mark prepared to meet
Oliver outside of the derelict old house,
he could feel pangs of regret deep in his
stomach.
What was he thinking?
Was a car really worth living his worst nightmare?
What if Oliver didn't honor the deal?
Or worse...what if the stories were actually
true?
He swallowed the lump in his throat as he
shoved a sandwich into his backpack.
He had food, water, a blanket, a flashlight,
and his phone.
Everything he should need to survive the night.
It would be fine!
...He hoped.
"Wasn't sure if you'd show!"
Oliver smirked as Mark walked up to meet him
on the rickety front porch.
"Well, I did.
I'm here," Mark fidgeted nervously, staring
up at the house, its windows gazing down at
him like large, dark eyes.
"So, here are the rules: You have to stay
here until sunrise.
You leave before then, the deal's off.
No car for you.
And you have to stay alone.
No calling for help from your little friends
or your mommy and daddy.
I'll be back to check on you in the morning
and make sure you really did it.
Got it?"
"Got it."
Mark nodded.
"Good luck, I'm rooting for you.
Really."
Oliver turned to leave, then glanced over
his shoulder for one final dig.
"Oh, and: Watch out for the ghost.
I hear if she gets you, there won’t even
be bones left over.
Night!"
And with that, he walked away.
Mark stared down at the doorknob, preparing
himself to walk inside.
He could still leave.
He could turn and run all the way back home.
But then Oliver would be right, and he would
be a coward.
No, he was going to do it.
He wasn't some scared little kid anymore.
It was just a big, empty house.
Nothing more.
He slowly turned the doorknob, pushed, and
with a long, low creak, the door opened to
the darkness within.
Against his better judgment, Mark instinctively
called out, "Hello?"
There was, thankfully, no response.
Just his voice echoing in the vast, empty
room.
He let out a small sigh of relief, and pulled
the flashlight out of his backpack, switching
it on.
He cast its beam around the front room of
the house, illuminating water damage, cobwebs
that he could only hope were no longer housing
any spiders, and a whole lot of plastic-wrapped
furniture.
As he walked into the living room, he was
struck by just how ordinary it all seemed.
It was creepy, of course, like any place made
for living that had been deprived of its purpose
for too long, but it wasn't nearly as bad
as his imagination had built it up to be.
He had been picturing black candles, symbols
drawn on the floor in blood, a skeleton perched
on the couch, bats hanging from the ceiling.
But there was none of that.
No ghosts, no signs of danger.
This was just...mostly sort of sad.
Once a home, now just a house, emptied out
and left to decay.
He could get through the night just fine.
As soon as he thought that, he felt something
scurry across his foot, and let out a scream.
The flashlight revealed it to be a large rat,
running from his sudden intrusion and looking
for a place to hide.
He clutched at his chest, catching his breath.
It's just an animal.
It's fine.
It's not going to hurt you, he reminded himself.
Now that some of the mystery was gone, he
was starting to wonder what the rest of the
house looked like.
What had once been breathless fear was replaced
with a certain morbid curiosity.
If he had to be here all night, he might as
well explore.
Hey, he thought to himself with a smile.
Exposure therapy really works!
Scared of a haunted house?
Just go roaming around inside in the middle
of the night.
You'll be cured!
He sat his backpack down next to the stairs,
keeping a grip on his flashlight, and began
to investigate the rest of his greatest childhood
fear.
He walked through the dining room, taking
in the ornate chandelier hanging from the
ceiling, the long, long table fit for hosting
at least a dozen guests.
He wandered into the kitchen, the appliances
rusty from neglect, the oven, and stove where
someone once prepared their nightly dinners.
All the pieces of a life, strewn about like
an unfinished jigsaw puzzle with no one to
pick up the pieces.
Suddenly, Mark heard something coming from
the other room.
It couldn't be...but it sounded like footsteps
on the stairs.
Someone, or something, walking down, descending
the staircase toward him.
He held his breath, heart pounding so hard
he could hear it in his ears.
The footsteps stopped, and the house was silent
once again.
Then, slowly, deliberately, he heard the same
footsteps heading back up, until they faded
away, too quiet to hear anymore.
That wasn't his imagination.
He was not alone in the house.
Carefully, he tiptoed back the way he came,
careful not to make too much noise walking
across the creaking floorboards.
When he reached the stairs, he saw no signs
of anyone else.
In fact, there was nothing there at all.
Wait..where was his backpack?
He scanned the floor, certain he had just
overlooked it, misremembered where he sat
it down.
But no matter where he looked, it wasn't there.
His stomach dropped with a sudden realization:
whoever he had heard coming down the stairs
must have taken it!
He thought briefly about abandoning it, just
running out the front door and never looking
back, but...his phone was in there!
If his parents found out, he'd be grounded
for months!
Not to mention, he wouldn't have a phone.
But what if whoever took it was dangerous?
He couldn't be sure, but something in his
gut told him he needed to go upstairs and
check it out.
He considered the weight of the flashlight
in his hand.
If someone attacked him, would it be enough
to defend himself?
He sure hoped so.
With shaky hands and unsteady legs, he began
to climb the stairs to the second floor of
the house.
Maybe whoever had taken his backpack was just
as scared of him as he was of them?
It was a comforting thought, though the comfort
was short-lived.
As he started down the upstairs hall, preparing
to search the first bedroom, he heard a door
creak open behind him.
He turned, and froze in wide-eyed terror at
the sight.
There was a figure there emerging from the
shadows, a pale woman with long, dark hair,
wearing a white nightgown, reaching out to
him with a clawed hand.
"Get...out..."
A voice rasped.
Mark shrieked, dropped the flashlight, and
tore back down the stairs.
He ran to the front door, but as his hand
touched the doorknob, a hand grabbed his ankle
and pulled.
He toppled over, landing on the ground with
a painful thud.
"Please..." He sobbed, shaking from fear.
"Don't hurt me.
I'll leave.
I'm so sorry.
Don't kill me!"
He braced himself for an unearthly voice,
for pain, but instead he heard gleeful cackling.
He opened his eyes and saw Oliver standing
above him.
"I knew you couldn't do it.
You're such a chicken."
He smirked.
"W-what?"
Mark stammered.
"Come on, did you really think I was gonna
give you my car?
Are you stupid?"
Oliver scoffed.
"Clearly."
Mark followed the sound of the new voice,
coming from the stairs.
There was Chase, one of Oliver's equally awful
friends.
"He still believes in haunted houses.
Did you like my work?
Made it myself."
He held up what Mark could now see was a prop,
a mannequin dressed up like some kind of ghostly
woman.
"You gave it a good try, but I think it's
time for you to run along home now," Oliver
sneered.
"Yeah, run home- oof!"
Chase's taunt was cut off, as he fell against
the banister suddenly.
"What the hell, who pushed me?"
He whirled around, but there was no one on
the stairs with him.
Still, Mark could hear the sound of footsteps
hammering past Chase and toward him and Oliver.
What happened next shocked him to his core.
Oliver was dragged to his feet by the collar
of his shirt, pulled by an unseen force.
Then, with a loud thwack, something invisible
hit him square in the nose.
"Ow!"
He cried out.
But before he could react anymore, he was
dealt another blow to the stomach, doubling
over in pain.
"What the-"
Something swept his legs out from under him,
and he fell hard, head hitting the floor with
a crack.
Then, it was quiet.
Oliver was still breathing but very much unconscious,
blood trickling from his nose.
"Screw this!"
Chase yelled, bolting out the door.
As Mark scrambled toward the door to follow
him, to run home before he could be attacked
next, he saw his backpack sliding across the
floor toward him.
"Thanks for the sandwich."
A female voice said, though he couldn't see
the source.
"I love peanut butter."
"You're welcome," he stammered, before grabbing
his bag and sprinting all the way home.
As the story of the haunted house began to
spread, rumors and local news reports alike
reached the ears of the SCP Foundation.
Foundation staff in the area placed infrared
cameras around the abandoned house, and the
footage captured a human heat signature.
Whatever was in that house, it was no ghost.
Using infrared cameras to track the entity,
it was quickly brought into custody.
Before long, the entity was opening up to
the Foundation, and she offered to cooperate
willingly in exchange for warm food and shelter.
So, the invisible woman was taken to a nearby
Foundation Site, and given the official classification:
SCP-347.
SCP-347 is a young adult woman, standing at
approximately 164cm tall.
For all intents and purposes, she is a completely
average woman, with one exception: she is
completely invisible to the naked eye.
This includes her body, as well as everything
inside of it including her blood, skin, and
hair samples.
Though the cones and rods of the human eye
must be visible in order to see, SCP-347's
vision has registered as normal following
extensive tests.
She refers to herself with the name "Claudia,"
though this is assumed to be an alias inspired
by Claude Rains, the lead actor in "The Invisible
Man."
Her real identity, if she indeed has one,
has not yet been confirmed.
Aside from her invisibility, SCP-347's only
other notable traits are an ability to pick
locks, a talent for thievery, and the ability
to swallow small objects in order to turn
them invisible, and then cough them up at
a later time without any sickness or discomfort.
She seems to crave human contact and socialization,
becoming frustrated when she is ignored.
She will act out in these cases by pranking
people, and rearranging and hiding their things.
When she is left alone with someone who is
sleeping, she has been known to stroke their
hair, touch their face, or tuck them in.
She does this, she says, because it just feels
"right."
However, those it is done to tend to describe
the behavior as "unnerving."
Though she is invisible in terms of visible
light, she can be seen using infrared or ultraviolet
cameras.
SCP-347 is currently contained at Site 1,
kept in a 5m x 5m room monitored with an infrared
camera.
The room has an attached bathroom complete
with a shower and bathtub, a queen-sized bed,
two armchairs, a desk and swivel chair, several
bookcases, a TV, and a DVD player.
Her bookcases are filled with books, mainly
adventure stories, romance novels, and art
books, as per her request.
She has also been permitted DVD copies of
any movies or television shows that she asks
for, as long as they pre-date her arrival
at the SCP Foundation.
New releases may be added, but only after
prior approval from the research team.
Though she does not frequently wear clothes,
she is to be provided with any clothing that
she requests, as well as a collection of makeup
and wigs.
She has been encouraged to dress up to her
heart's content, as it allows Foundation staff
to more easily gauge her location at any given
time.
While she is inside, the door to her room
must remain locked.
At least two staff members must check her
door every hour for signs of tampering with
the lock.
The door may only be unlocked to allow staff
in and out for interviews, research, and the
delivery of meals and other requested items.
She thoroughly enjoys human company, and will
chat, joke, and even flirt with those who
visit her room.
She is permitted to leave her containment
if and only if she is accompanied by a staff
member with at least Level-2 security clearance,
as well as wearing a layer of grease paint
on her face and gloves on her hands.
This allows the staff to see her hands and
facial expressions.
While she is out and about, staff are instructed
to treat her with respect and avoid making
any rude or crass comments about her invisibility,
or her state of dress - or undress.
If she attempts to escape, she is to be returned
to her room and locked inside.
If the staff are unable to detect SCP-347's
location, they will be given infrared heat
vision goggles and instructed to keep an eye
out for unusual phenomena.
Dr. Rights added an addendum to her official
file, warning male personnel to politely decline
any advances that SCP-347 makes toward them.
His note reads:
"She's an invisible kleptomaniac.
When you leave, afterward, you're going to
realize three seconds too late that you don't
have your keys in your pocket anymore, and
you will be held accountable for whatever
happens.
Besides, the last thing we need is an invisible
pregnancy.
-Dr. Rights"
When she was first contained, SCP-347 had
regular violent outbursts and displayed signs
of emotional instability, including compulsive
theft and depressive episodes during which
she would give all surrounding people the
silent treatment.
Her condition has improved gradually over
time with the application of regular counseling
sessions intended to help her heal from the
trauma caused by years of complete isolation
and being unseen by the world around her.
Several of the research staff studying Claudia
have suggested that she be introduced to other
SCPs, particularly those who are humanoid
and considered to be non-threatening.
She might, they posit, benefit from social
interaction with other anomalous beings that
she can relate and connect to.
This, in addition to her therapy, could improve
her mental and emotional state significantly.
After all, just because she's invisible, that
doesn't mean she has to feel invisible too.
Claudia has expressed a great deal of interest
in this idea, stating that it would be nice
to have some friends on the inside who aren't
being paid to talk to her.
Though no match-ups have been approved as
of yet, several anomalies have been proposed
should the program be put into action.
SCP-507 was brought up in conversation by
more than one researcher, given his harmless
nature, friendly demeanor, and fascination
with the paranormal.
He supported the idea enthusiastically, stating
that he would be thrilled to meet a real live
invisible person.
SCP-343 has also asked to meet with Claudia,
believing he can potentially help her overcome
some of her emotional difficulties, and offer
her some much-needed comfort.
Other potential anomalies to introduce to
Claudia include SCP-073 and SCP-056, though
Claudia's flirtatious nature might complicate
the latter.
Everybody wants to be known, to be acknowledged
and recognized for the person that they know
themselves to be.
For SCP-347, it once seemed as if having that
simple desire, that human need, met, would
be impossible for her.
But now, for better or for worse, as long
as she's in the custody of the SCP Foundation,
Claudia can make something approximating a
normal life.
She can, at last, be seen.
Now go check out “SCP-811 - Swamp Woman”
and “SCP-953 - Polymorphic Humanoid” for
even more lovely - and not so lovely - anomalous
ladies!